This episode is sponsored by Google play with the help of [inaudible] still
alive. The dark fantasy open-world RPG
From the love child of Tim burden and Peewee Herman. When we made evil dead, I.
Wanting to make, do something that.
Who's produced so much cool stuff throughout his career,
but a whole generation only knows him for directing the Spiderman means
pizza time comes the mind blowing trilogy that was making you laugh and scream
at the same time. Long before he cast over Grace's venom. I like being bad.
It makes me happy.
The evil dead franchise
scrap in for three excellent flicks that barely hang together as an actual
trilogy,
evil dead one where some dumb teens drive all the way from Michigan to the
worst little Airbnb in Tennessee, evil,
dead to a half remake,
half parody of the first one with a ratio of horror to comedy swapped
and evil dead three, which is called army of darkness,
but a direct sequel to evil dead two,
and is really more like a medieval times three Stooges movie.
They're all great in their own ways though. Consistencies for nerds,
Bruce Campbell stars. As this handsome piece of Ash,
he's got a chin like a clenched fist and a literally handy chainsaw.
Our hero will begin the trilogy as one of the more dumb and cowardly leading men
in film history.
[Inaudible].
Unable to overpower even the nearest shelving unit until he goes through so much
head trauma over the course of two films
That he turns into Duke NewCo. Come get some, give me some sugar,
baby Harold to King hail to the King. Baby
evil will rise when Ash stumbles across an ancient godkids sketchbook and
accidentally plays a curse podcast to summon the dead eyes, their parts, zombie.
[Inaudible].
Part vampire
and all SAS.
I'm bad at.
You're good.
As these demons resort to the one trick in their evil book possess one of your
loved ones, then briefly pretend to be back to normal.
Jane. And let me out shell.
How old is he keep falling for this.
Alloys and compositions and things with molecular structures in the
Oh right. Moron.
Thrill at films that are as light on substance as they are heavy with style as
Sam Raimi turns on no clip mode for his camera, running it through the woods.
[Inaudible].
Like a lot, smashing it through windows.
Getting extremely close up
and doing basically whatever he thought it looks fun and cool at the time from
the awesome gearing up montages,
Groovy to the constant decapitations.
[Inaudible].
To having a tree sexually assaulted a woman.
Uh, moving on. So enjoy these classic drive-in movies.
Pass down through the generations of cool older siblings and weird uncles that
proves you didn't need huge budgets and movie stars to make an awesome film.
In fact,
you didn't even really have to know how to make a film to make an awesome film
focus. Just your old car, your high school buddy,
and another red dyed corn syrup to flood the Eastern seaboard.
[Inaudible].
Man, I cannot wait to see him do this to Benedict Cumberbatch,
stupid clean faced handsome man story Ash,
kilo deuce Campbell burn. After reading,
I am Groot the King Lord mullet of Bogut
blend off loose sous.
Halloween, Halloween, Halloween, but bill.
These are historical Babs and.
I'm talking to the man in the mirror.
My face.
The dead chainsaw massacre.
The scariest part of these films is when Bruce Campbell comes close to getting
canceled.
Definitely careful.
This episode is sponsored by Google play.
Get a three still alive and discover more on Google play. Now, uh,
just to drink a martini shaken, not stirred. Give me some sugar.
Oh no, not the bees, not the bees. Oh, they're in my eyes.
Oh,